Rugbyman du 15 de France,
Bastien chaluro,
coupable à leurs yeux de violence raciste.
De fait, en deux-mille-vingt,
le tribunal correctionnel de Toulouse
avait condamné à 6 mois de prison Bastien chaluro.
Celui-ci ni les fait, il a fait appel,
il bénéficie donc de la présomption d'innocence.
La France insoumise ignore les lois de ce pays.
La France insoumise rend la justice sur Twitter,
elle rétablit les comités de salut public.
Les petits nouveaux docteurs guillotins
prennent le modèle sur le sanguinaire Mara,
l'ami du peuple sous la terreur,
l'homme qui dressait des listes et envoyé
tout à chacun sur l'échafaud,
à 4 jours de François le Black.
Les 6 cophantes de l'extrême gauche
aiment à rendre l'atmosphère de ce pays irrespirable.
Dénonciation et lynchage
sont leurs armes favorites. Sauf évidemment
quand l'un des leurs est au cœur d'une polémique.
Adrien katnas a droit à plus d'égards
quand il tabasse son épouse.
Ainsi marche la France insoumise.
Aujourd'hui c'est chaluro,
demain la meute trouvera 1 autre client.
La soif d'exécution
publique de ces gens est inépuisable.